let's talk about the word collusion the
word collusion has come up surprisingly
frequently on political programs for the
last year and a half and recently I've
been telling you how the narrative
around Russian collusion has shifted
drastically from there was no collusion
to collusion wouldn't be illegal first
it was just right-wing media we heard on
Fox and Friends like a year ago
collusion is not actually a crime more
recently it was Donald Trump's lawyer
Rudy Giuliani who started saying I don't
even know where collusion exists in the
criminal code and then over the weekend
we finally got to Donald Trump himself
who admitted that yeah we intended to
work with Russia to get damaging
information about Hillary Clinton at
that Trump Tower meeting but the
argument is it wasn't illegal so one of
the stories is the moving of the
goalposts that's a big part of the story
and I've already explained to you how
just because collusion doesn't show up
by name in the criminal code colluding
with a foreign country can encompass
many crimes receiving things of value
from foreign countries for the purposes
of Elections obstruction of justice
conspiracy campaign finance violations
there's this very long list of actual
codified crimes that could fall under
the umbrella of collusion but let's put
that aside for a second let's skip the
semantic argument about whether
collusion is the crime or merely
describes the crime because Donald Trump
has actually already said he believes
collusion is a crime there's a really
good piece in The Washington Post by
Erin Blake which points this out and it
points out that if collusion isn't a
crime
why has Donald Trump been insisting for
months now or maybe even even even
longer than that that Hillary Clinton
and the Democrats colluded with Russia
and should be investigated if it's not a
crime to collude with Russia why would
Donald Trump suggest anybody be
investigated for it here's one recent
example from Donald Trump's Twitter
where he said quote collusion with
Russia was very real Hillary Clinton and
her team 100% colluded with the Russians
and so did Adam Schiff who is on tape
trying to collude with what he thought
was Russians to obtain compromising
material on Donald J Trump we already
know that Hillary Clinton paid through a
law firm eventually creme
connected sources to gather info on
Donald Trump collusion is very real with
Russia but only with Hillary and the
Democrats and we should demand a full
investigation as Erin Blake points out
one would launch an investigation into
Hillary colluding with Russia
if illegal activity was suspected if
it's collusion with Russia
that's suspected and that's not a crime
why would you start an investigation
into Hillary's collusion with Russia
this isn't a one-off from Donald Trump
it's happened time and again
June 8th Trump suggested Democrats
should be investigated for collusion and
obstruction of justice July 29th Donald
Trump tweeted why is Muller only
appointing angry Dems some of whom have
worked for crooked Hillary others
including himself have worked for Obama
and why isn't Muller looking at all of
the criminal activity and real Russian
collusion on the Democrats side Podesta
dossier if it's not a crime why would
you suggest Muller look into it Donald
Trump even said in an interview that
collusion is corruption and thus it
warrants investigation he made a huge
deal out of it take a look at this this
is very big and frankly it's
unbelievable what was just found out is
that the Department of Justice the State
Department and the FBI colluded got
together to make Hillary Clinton look
less guilty and look a lot better than
she looks this is one of the big
breaking stories of our time in my
opinion this shows corruption at the
highest level collusion is corruption at
the highest level so of course who cares
what the legal argument is that Trump is
making legally he's clueless the real
issue is when you lie all the time the
lies start to conflict there was no
Russian meddling and why didn't bomb
approve en't the Russian meddling
because it started under his watch wait
wait is that if it didn't happen what is
there for Obama to prevent collusion
isn't a crime but Hillary colluded and
should be investigated for it the bottom
line is that the primary idea continues
to be I
didn't do it but if I did it wasn't a
crime but if others did it it is a crime
and they are the ones who should
actually be investigated and sadly it's
stupid enough to possibly work because
it's already convinced endless endless
trumpets look at the discussions that
are taking place in the Trump friendly
recesses of the internet they have
fallen for this hook line & sinker it's
not illegal
why's Trump saying Hillary should be
investigated for it send me your
thoughts you can also discuss this on
the David Pakman show
subreddit at david pakman.com slash our
EDD IT quick break great interview
coming up next today's program is
sponsored in part by Blink accom slash
Pakman if you've not already heard about
blinka s-- it's amazing it's an app for
your phone tablet or web browser and
what they do is they take nonfiction
books popular nonfiction critically
acclaimed nonfiction they condense the
book into a fifteen minute audio book
you get all the most important
information and insights from each book
but you can soak up the entire essence
of the book in one sitting
I've listened to a ton of books on
blinkin recent one is a Robert Rice's
new book the common good also bunk by
Kevin Young useful in preparing me for
the pseudo-science miniseries that we're
producing and if you are a david pakman
show viewer or listener you can get a
seven day free trial by going to blink
accom slash Pakman if you're watching on
youtube use the link in the video
description
after the free trial if you like it you
can get the full access to thousands of
condensed audiobooks for about five
bucks a month that's be li NK is t.com
/pa ke ma n